- 1:15 A.M.
DRock and I, hotel.
That's how we do it.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
- [Gary] I haven't
seen anything yet.
I need her.
Where's Yudkin?
What?
Let's go guys,
it's 1 o'clock, Garrett.
I need Yudkin.
I need him, you got to find him.
- We're just preparing
so if you saw us.
- [Gary] What's this,
your favorite app?
- [Man] What app
do you open first?
- [Gary] What app
Gary.
- Saffer. Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure.
- Raj, I just started yesterday.
- Real pleasure, welcome man.
'Preciate you guys are here.
What do I open up first?
I don't even know
what I open up first.
Hello.
How are you?
Good afternoon.
(audience applause and cheers)
Happy New Year to everybody.
Hope, everybody had
a good little break?
- [Audience] Yeah.
(cheers)
- So, I'm sure at this point
seen the acquisition of PureWow
and I'm sure you've done your
homework if you
knew it or you didn't.
This is an acquisition, this
is a another media conglomerate
like the way Hearst
owns seven things,
now we own The Gallery, we
own PureWow and we may start a
Knicks media company that you're
gonna want to be a part of.
No?
Pirates?
Got it.
I'm bummed about
the Knicks, too.
Any other questions?
Jesus Christ, Loomis.
You couldn't be further away?
(audience laughter)
You're literally the single
furthest away fucking person.
Oh no, Justin, got it,
if that's Justin.
I can't even see
that fucking far.
Alright, go ahead.
Great question.
So the question is like how is
this different than a
holding company?
Obviously, we're beholden
to me at the highest level and
how is this different?
This is a great opportunity,
this is why Q&amp;A's the best.
This is why we're gonna
do a lot more of this.
Let me explain what that means.
The structure of a
holding company is not bad.
You're more than welcome
to own multiple businesses.
That's just smart and fine.
The problem is when you're only
giving advice to your clients in
your own financial
vested interest.
The way we're different is if
the Dove team want to give
$48 million to
Refinery 29, Mazel Tov.
It doesn't bother
me and that's it.
I don't know what
else to tell you.
Just simple as that.
It's not super complicated.
I think the difference is is
that holding companies are at
the highest level publicly
traded companies on Wall Street
that have to hit a margin so the
stock price goes to a certain
value so that the executives
making the decision get paid.
They don't own their company.
Even the top, top leader.
I do and I'm holding it forever
and so that's the distinction.
It's not so much that we
don't have different things.
It's the religion and the
actions that you preach.
You know and so many people here
have been in holding company
environments and understand
how many decisions
are made for that reason.
So, that's how I see it
that it's different, you know?
And so, if our media department
now started telling everybody
don't buy anything but banner
ads on PureWow, that's bad.
But if we get unbelievable deals
and work together tremendously
well and that's a good deal
for them than great.
But there's no reason if you're
targeting 13 to 17-year-old
dudes that you should even
worry about what's
going on at PureWow.
(light jazz music)
Awesome, have a great day.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
Go to work.
(audience laughter)
Pound her.
The best part about that,
that's why I took it there.
We have to do
town hall, start talking.
- Yes.
- Town hall, we will win.
You have great color.
Where'd you go?
Yeah.
You good?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Good, right?
- Thanks, Gary.
Can I give you a hug?
- [Gary] Mar.
(light jazz music)
How are you, man?
- [Man 2] I didn't
appreciate it, man.
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Man 2] I didn't
appreciate that, man.
- [Gary] What?
The razz of the...
You excited, man?
You must be freaking out.
- [Man 2] It's awesome. I mean
I don't expect much but...
- [Gary] Who you guys playing?
Steelers?
- Steelers.
- [Gary] At Pittsburgh.
- Yep.
- [Gary] Tough game.
- We'll see.
- [Gary] Hey.
Yeah, good luck.
- [Man 3] And that's my fault.
- [Gary] Well,
let's make it happen.
- [Man 3] Yeah, totally.
- [Gary] Hit up the Ty-guy.
Yes, (inaudible)
that's exactly right.
- [Man 3] Walk a little faster.
- [Gary] She's still alive.
She just works on
different things now.
You know the
answer to that, right?
The answer to that
is absolutely not.
(DRock laughs)
Any time you put
the camera down there's
brilliance spewing directly
out of my fucking mouth
every minute, Andy.
That's right, I'm
editing this eBay video,
yes, amazingness comes.
I talk to Andy I give
him something great,
no, you've got camera
fucking sitting down.
Like I don't understand
what this strategy is here.
- Greg's here, you
want him in your office?
- [Gary] Yeah,
bring him in here.
Did anybody say hello?
You say hello to anybody?
With the name tags?
- [Andy] No.
(DRock laughs)
Just being honest.
I'll shake some hands.
- Go in the cafeteria right now.
Follow him, DRock.
That's it.
That's what's happening.
Andy, that's it.
That's what's
happening right now.
(light jazz music)
- How you doin', man?
I'm Andy.
- I'm Joey.
Nice to meet you.
- [Andy] What's
you're favorite app?
The app you open first.
(music drowns out speakers)
- [Durian] Instagram?
- [Andy] Instagram, yeah.
Solid. Is that true?
- I think so, yeah.
I usually go to Facebook.
- [DRock] In the morning?
- It's got news,
it's got updates.
- I spend so much
time on Facebook,
I just never really consume
anything for my personal use.
- Yeah. Oh, you mean for work?
Yeah.
- Yeah, at work I'm in
Facebook 80% of the day.
WhatsApp?
- Yes.
- [Andy] You're international.
You're talking to
all your friends?
- Well, my sister.
My sister lives in Italy.
- [Andy] In Italy?
- In Italy, yeah.
They started talking to me,
texting me around 2 A.M.
Over there,
it's 8 so that's it,
in the morning
it's okay, what's up?
Hi, sisters.
(laughs)
- [Gary] How are things?
- [Man 4] Good.
Yourself?
- [Gary] Good.
- You may recognize
(inaudible) at...
- [Woman] We met at (inaudible).
- Yes, I do
remember that actually.
Of course, I remember.
I remember.
You're welcome.
I do remember that.
- [Man 4] We'll get into
the dynamics of tier 3, right?
- Mom and Pop.
- [Man 4] Mom and Pop. Right.
- I don't know if you guys want
to zoom in and I don't know how
you guys want to
edit this video,
but you should really,
really zoom in on this sign,
this thing right here
because I'm Mom and Pop.
- [Man 4] I know you are.
- I'm sure that's why
you asked the question.
- [Man 4] That's right.
- My friends, I have good news.
I'm just like you.
My dad had a $3.6 million a
year revenue liquor store.
One store unit in New Jersey.
I came to this
country with nothing.
My dad did, I was a
four year old child.
He made two bucks an hour.
I worked as a 13-year-old in
his small store in Springfield.
Learned the business,
plenty of you watching,
I've really learned your space.
It's why I love
you guys so much.
It's why I want to do this.
- [Man 4] Right.
- You grew up at
your grandpappy's shop,
you bought into the business
or you grinded saved all you're
money for 18 years and
bought your own dealership.
I know what you're dealing with.
- [Man 4] Right.
- It's why I'm so
passionate that I'm right.
- [Man 4] Right.
- There's a reason I grew my
dad's Mom and Pop store from
a 3 to a $60 million
business in five years.
This isn't about
me writing books.
This is about I did it and
I did for 15 years and then
after I did it
I started talking.
- [Man 4] Mhmmm.
- So, yes.
I much more the people in
this conference than the fancy
conferences I speak that
are marketers as corporate
environment executives.
- [Man 4] Right.
- I'm more like you
where every dollar matters.
I'm telling you this 'cause
I don't want you to waste money.
You think this is scary and
you're gonna waste money
'cause it might not work.
I know that what you're spending
money on right now is not
working as well as
you think it is.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- [Man 4] Right.
- So, yeah I think that one of
the reasons I've done quite well
in this environment is, shit,
if my dad didn't have a liquor
store and had a car dealership,
I would've been the
car dealership guy.
- [Man 4] Right.
- This is very much my domain.
This is about selling
and marketing and
I'm very empathetic.
My first marketing budget
for Wine Library I built that
business from 3 to $60 million
with a $8,000 marketing budget
as the first year's budget.
- [Man 4] Wow.
- I had no money.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Man 4] Right.
- So we have no money, when you
guys are spending $20,000 a year
or $8,000 a month
you can't waste it.
- [Man 4] Right.
- [Woman] Right.
- And the only way not to waste
it is buy something that people
don't think is valuable.
- [Man 4] Right.
- You're overpaying
for radio, billboard,
local commercials
because it's established.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- [Man 4] Right.
- You're under-buying an
influencer who is taking a
selfie at your car lot for $58
or $290 or $4,000 but is worth
$80,000 because 857,000
people follow them on Instagram.
- [Man 4] Right.
- This is basic.
- [Man 4] How do you get them
to take that leap of faith?
- I do it aggressively as
you're seeing in this interview.
- [Woman and Man 4] Yeah.
- I punched them in the face.
I give them no wiggle room.
I don't pander to them.
I tell them they're big
fucking boys and girls.
This is what's up and I don't
give a shit if they do or not.
- [Man 4] Right.
- I'm coming to
Atlanta to bring it--
- [Man 4] Right.
- and then I don't care,
your not my mom.
- [Man 4] You're right.
- I don't give a crap
if any of them do it.
- [Man 4] Right. Right.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- How I get them to do it?
By giving it my all on the
field and if they don't do it,
that's their loss and then when
I see them in four years and
I see these people, too, that
come up to me and says,
"I wish I started four years
ago when you told him."
I go, "I told you."
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- I don't make them
feel good about it.
- [Man 4] Right.
- I do, when somebody
comes up to me and says,
"Damn it, I saw you four years
ago in Vegas at this conference.
"We're just doing it now, it's
working but my competitor did it
"and it crushed us.
I wish I listened to you."
I do not say it's not too late.
I said, "You deserve to lose."
- [Man 4] Right.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- Okay.
- [Man 4] You gave more
than your fair share of time
so we appreciate that.
- My pleasure.
- Thank you.
Thank you, so much.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
Take care.
I love, good energy, right?
- Last time he came with me...
- That part, that's the
same as me and my, yeah.
- Yeah.
- A lot.
Well, great, I hope
you have a great day.
I'm so glad we got to meet.
You're welcome.
Love ya, pal.
- Thanks, man.
- Talk to you.
- [Woman 2] I come from the
world of retail and fashion and
so I want to try and
branch out and also
get into some other industries.
- [Gary] Yeah, good for you.
Anything I can answer for you?
- Just, I guess, it's
been about six months now,
so do you have any advice?
The biggest thing for me
is I want feedback and--
- [Gary] We're not the
greatest organization for that.
I think feedback
from my standpoint is
being industry smart.
So if I give you a real
good piece of feedback,
I would read an hour
a day on what's going on
with e-com and discovering.
So, just even like searching
hashtags on Instagram finding a
emerging luxury brand, clicking.
What I, the reason I think I'm
the best strategist is 'cause
I'm always living it.
Nothing trumps going to
e-commerce websites for
20 minutes a day.
- [Woman 2] Yeah. Sure.
- Like, you know how much
smarter you would be if every
day, how do you get to work?
- [Woman 2] I take the subway.
- Perfect.
If you spent 10 minutes and
first of all maybe spend three
or four hours to figure out the
right strategy to be efficient
that allows you to go to
seven websites every single day.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- Do you how cool that is?
- It's the work.
- [Woman 2] Sure.
- It's always the work.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
For me, it's so natural
because I shop online
all the time I do a lot of--
- [Gary] But, as you
know, you shop for you.
- Well, yes.
- [Gary] Got it?
- That's, yes.
- [Gary] So, one week
you should go to
59 sports product sites
or like baby care.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm really into that.
So how's it going overall?
Good?
- [Woman 3] Yeah, it's great.
- [Gary] You enjoying
the culture, everything?
- The culture is fantastic.
- [Gary] Good.
- It's the best. Yeah.
Coming to 315
Wednesday of next week.
- [Woman 3] Oh yeah.
Yeah, I saw that.
- Good and what are you
working on right now?
- [Woman 3] (censored).
- Mhmmm.
- [Woman 3] Trying to
un-decommercialize those spots.
- Thank you very much.
- [Woman 3] Of course.
- That makes me very happy to
hear you say that sentence.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Tell me about yourself.
- I am from Los Angeles.
Went to film school in New York.
I spent about 12
years doing films.
Actually, that's
how I met this guy.
- [Gary] Oh, you
guys know each other?
- [DRock] Yup, from
"A Case Of You" right?
- Yeah, about five
or six years ago.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Gary] That's so cool.
- I saw him over here.
- [DRock] I did an
internship for free.
- [Gary] I know how you roll.
That's really neat.
That makes me happy.
- [Woman 3] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Awesome.
Have a great day.
- Thank you so much.
Nice meeting you.
- [Gary] Nice meeting you.
- See you.
- [DRock] Good seeing you.
- That's so fun.
- [DRock] Yeah.
What's cooking?
Weather, weather, weather.
- Weather, you know.
Everyone kept saying
alarm clock. It's not true.
- [Gary] Ah, that's good.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's good.
- I felt it was really important
what you said about if it's
right for your brand,
it's right for your brand.
If it's not right
for your brand,
it's not right for your brand.
- [Gary] It's the game changer.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It's why
we're gonna win.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] There's nothing else.
- [Lauren] A lot of
big agency world where,
part of the reason that
I came to an independent and
that doesn't have a holding
company is because I see all the
politics that go into
what you need to deliver
for your client based on--
- [Gary] Your interest.
- bottom line, yep. Exactly.
- [Gary] Yep.
Good. Awesome.
- [Lauren] Well, thanks, Gary.
- Take care.
- Have a great one.
- You too.
And so the culture's been great?
Everything's been great?
- Oh, everything's amazing.
- [Gary] You didn't know
what you were walking into.
- I didn't.
I was like, "Whoa,
everybody's really nice here."
- [Gary] (laughs) You
came home you're like...
- What's the catch?
- [Gary] When's the
other shoe gonna drop?
- Yeah, but
everybody's just awesome.
- [Gary] Good. What are you
working on right now?
(light jazz music)
My pleasure. Alright, brother.
- Alright. Have good one.
- Take care, have a great day.
Hey, did you guys see
I bought a media company?
The first piece of editorial
that I'm creating is the
10 best looking
people in agency world
and all three of
you made the list.
- [Man 5] (laughter)
You're gonna
immediately lose
all credibility.
- One of you's eight,
one of you is nine,
and one of you is ten.
I'll let you guys debate.
(DRock laughs)
Did you capture the
all hands on today?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- We showed the
Wall Street Journal part?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Put "Buying A Media Company".
"Buying A Media
Publishing Company"
'cause media, yeah, yeah.
- I see you as--
- [Gary] The greatest?
No, I'm sorry. (laughs)
- as the best guy ever!
First of all, your
office view is unbelievable.
- [Gary] Insane, right?
- Yeah, I've been a
Knick fan my whole life.
As like a personal influencer,
I can't tell them anything real.
I can say, "Hey, you got this"--
- [Gary] This many likes.
- "and impressions" and the fact
that Instagram gives up those
shitty engagement metrics,
it's mind-blowing at this point.
That was something great and
even that doesn't
really tell you anything.
So my main thing is--
- [Gary] Well, ironically,
it tells you just as much as
television commercials tell you.
The problem is these marketers,
because they
don't understand it,
want to believe it or
understand how to understand it,
want it to do something
they don't ask the other media
platforms to do for them.
- [Ben] Sure. That's true.
- The end.
- [Ben] That's true.
- What's TV telling you?
You think TV's telling them how
many bottles of Captain Morgan
are sold at the Wine Library?
- [Ben] No, it's not.
It's something that--
- [Gary] It's accepted
and it's worse data than
what you have right now.
So the answer to your question
on the fucking first day you get
to spend time with me is this.
It's just a matter of time.
Because when your contemporaries
are the decision makers,
this will be your norm.
- [Ben] As I think it should be.
- Of course, 'cause
it's actually happening.
- [Ben] Yeah, the proving
of return on investment,
which I agree is you don't need
to do that for any
other media outlets--
- [Gary] Oh shit.
- so why should you?
- [Gary] Can you
give me four seconds?
- Yeah. Not at all, no worries.
- [Gary] Actually can you
give me two seconds personal.
I have to do this call.
- [Ben] Yes.
- I'm sorry.
You too, DRock, sorry.
Give me one second, bud.
Got it.
I want to run a division for
small business that
looks like original Vayner.
- It really is.
You know the story, right?
I started off as an Uber
driver, picked up Alex,
missed his train and he told
me that he worked for you and
I just went crazy in the
seat while I was driving.
It was funny.
- [Gary] It's so insane, right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Alex missing his train
is why you work at VaynerMedia
for a guy you
liked and respected.
- [Chris] And it was crazy,
I was watching the video when
you guys first moved into
the office that same day.
- [DRock] That's awesome.
- Yeah, I was just
like, it was crazy.
- [Gary] Life is so nuts.
- It is.
- [Gary] It makes me so happy.
Like, I live for that story.
I like giving people at-bats.
Somethings work
out and some don't.
- [Chris] Mhmmm.
- But you're
doing good work, man.
- [Chris] Appreciate it.
- You know, one
thing a lot of people...
You know how I always talk
about college not
being very, you know?
One thing people like to
razz me about is like
"Hey,VaynerMedia,"
I'm like, "We do plenty
of rogue ass shit."
Including Alex De Simone's
Uber driver,
let's give him a chance.
And then, you know what's great
about the way I think I play is
as being somebody who doesn't
have a Harvard degree hanging,
you know, I don't give a
shit where anybody comes from.
What it looks, by the way,
you might've went to
fucking Columbia.
I have no idea what the fuck.
I don't know.
I don't really
know your background.
Here's what I know.
I know that I love that we can
fucking hire Uber drivers and
they can dominate and do the
kind of creative that you're
doing and that
excites the shit out of me.
- [Chris] Appreciate it.
Thanks.
- And I assume
you're learning a lot.
- Oh, yeah. Definitely.
I'm glad to be around a team
that's smarter than
me, more creative.
- [Gary] Of course.
- It challenges me to
work harder and--
- [Gary] Where you from?
- I'm from Queens
but I live in
Hempstead, Long Island.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Yeah. So, it's crazy.
(group laughter)
I don't even know.
I definitely wanted to get this
one-on-one to get acquainted.
- [Gary] I feel like we've been
warming up to each other anyway.
Yeah. Good, man.
- [Chris] Appreciate it.
- [Gary] My pleasure.
Ry, I'm a big fan of that.
I think a lot of people.
I haven't talked a lot this in
my content the last couple years
but back in the day I used to
talk a lot about get a 9 to 5,
obviously it'd be nice if you
liked it but get a 9 to 5 that
you have a lot of flexibility
with that pays your bills,
right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And then
allows you to then hustle,
back with Crush It!, 7 P.M.
to 2 in the morning. You know?
So I think that's exactly right.
It's practical, it's right.
Where do you work?
- I work at AT&amp;T
right now in sales.
(light jazz music)
(phone chiming)
- Oh,
- [Gary] There we go.
- I can not believe it.
Oh my gosh.
- [Gary] It's real.
- How are you, Gary?
- [Gary] I'm very
good, my friend.
How are you?
- I'm fine, I'm fine.
I'm here in Luxembourg.
- [Gary] Very nice.
Thanks for staying
up for so late.
- [Man 6] Few projects
next to my school.
I have an entrepreneur spirit.
- Good.
- [Man 6] No one else in my
family has it but I don't know
from where I got it.
(Gary laughs)
And I'm also involved
in network marketing.
It goes pretty good and
my big thing is
to change something
in this world,
to inspire the world in a
good way and to find a
big problem and find
the solution for it.
- Good for you.
- [Man 6] I don't
know where to go.
I don't know what to do.
- So here's what I would say,
let it come to you and
realize you have a long way to go.
You're a young man.
It's all those
cliche sayings, right?
Like the teacher comes when
you're ready for it
and all that stuff.
If you're trying to
find the world's problem,
you're usually
blinding yourself from it.
Live your life and react to
where you see there's pain or
issue and that's the
best way to find it.
- Do you care if I'm on this?
Do you want me on this?
- [Gary] The truth is it's gonna
be a non-conversation because
I don't have
everything figured out.
(group laughter)
That's a tough way to,
that's a tough way to...
Jeez, that sucks.
Poor Alex is like, "What?"
(group laughter)
- (inaudible) I'll be in there.
- It's okay,
I'll be in there, too.
- Alright.
- You should worry about you.
- Okay.
- I'll worry about me.
- Alright?
- Cool.
- Yeah.
I might also go directly to
sleep so then you'll have to
worry about me
tomorrow but it's good, man.
Off to the races.
- [Tyler] Exactly.
- [Gary] A lot of
this stuff is fluff.
Today was a unique day.
- [Tyler] Totally.
Babcock's a huge,
they're from Boulder, right?
Boulder, Denver, yeah.
- [Man 7] All American made.
Hand made.
- I don't like American made.
- [Man 7] You don't
like American made?
Why is that?
- Overpriced.
- [Man 7] Overpriced?
(group laughter)
- The fact that, I literally
don't think I know where
anything I have in
the world is made.
Zero.
Zero knowledge of anything.
- [Man 7] When they
say American made,
they usually tout it.
- [Gary] Yeah,
but I don't pay attention.
(hip hop music)
Where's Avi?
So, if I said to
you go backwards,
what would be the ideal thing?
What would that look like?
- [Man 8] I really don't know.
- [Gary] First of all,
I like that answer.
'Cause I just want
the truth, right?
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- There's nothing
wrong with that.
But I do think
that's super important.
And not that you have
to make one decision and
then you stick to it forever.
Let me say something here that
I actually thought for the first
time the other day.
It was interesting to me that it
was crossing my mind the other
day, as you know 'cause you've
been following me for some time
based on what you just said,
there's a lot more going on
with me over the
last six months and
this year than
there was before, right?
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- So, you know it crossed
my mind the other day like,
"Wow, will I freak out in three
years and just want to spend one
"year with my whole family?"
And be like, hey, I want it.
I felt like there was this
really powerful piece of content
that ran through my
mind like I love hustling,
I'm 24/7, I want to buy the Jets
but right now what I really want
to do is spend one year, every
minute with Misha and Xander
while they're 10 and 7
and I'm gonna go do that.
See ya.
And how much that
would be very much on,
that would be the
most macro version of
what I've always been saying.
Which is when you know
what you want to do,
go do it and that's like
the only thing and so there's
nothing wrong with you not
knowing exactly what you want to
do but I do think it's
important to always,
I don't think there's anything
wrong with changing what you
want to do but I do think in
every moment if you have the
ability to understand
what you want to do,
that's important.
- [Man 8] Yes.
- [Gary] So the reason I'm going
crazy and 24/7 and all this
insanity is I have this
insane ambition of profession.
(hip hop music)
1:14 in the morning, big day.
Big bucks, media exploded,
social media exploded.
Big announcement of PureWow.
Just get back in the grind.
Tons of new business.
In New Orleans here for
12 hours, speech in the morning.
Heading out to CES,
Vegas where DailyVee started?
- [DRock] No.
Third episode.
- Third episode but we had
the big episode in Vegas.
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- Excited about that.
And living the dream.
1:15 A.M.
DRock and I, hotel.
That's how we do it.
See ya later.
(hip hop music)